[Música]
recuerden el inicio del ciclo de clases
que sucede en el aula llegan los alumnos
se sientan esperan a que llegue el
maestro ya tienen una rutina
probablemente el maestro se va a parar y
va a decir esto es mi nombre
esta es la materia y esto es lo que
vamos a ver durante el semestre a mí me
gusta hacer las cosas un poco diferentes
mi nombre es yang ya y como tengo un
nombre tan único a veces tengo que
explicárselo a mis alumnos entonces les
digo me llamo sean ya su carga de
confusión como si no estuviera
equivocando de pronunciar mi propio
nombre les digo jean-jacques solo
conmigo ya ya ya cuando tienen dominado
mi nombre les digo no se preocupen me
pueden decir maestro en ese momento o
ver que sus caras cambian completamente
de estar serios aburridos a sonreír
a tener ese destello en sus ojos de que
algo diferente va a pasar y algunos de
ellos a reírse y eso es lo que me gusta
me apasiona ser maestra me apasiona
poder ver cómo se transforman sus
rostros y sus mentes durante un semestre
la pasión es una palabra que me ha
perseguido por muchos años
específicamente cuando la descubrí en un
mensaje en una galleta de la fortuna en
un restaurante chino que era realmente
imaginar manejado por mexicanos en un
pueblo de 8000 personas en arkansas
para esto imagínense que la frase decía
solo las grandes pasiones pueden elevar
el alma a realizar grandes cosas
esta frase realmente llena de sabiduría
dije cómo es posible que una galleta en
la fortuna esté pasando pero realmente
venía de el pensador denis diderot
entonces en ese momento me di cuenta que
estaba en el lugar indicado porque
estaba marcando un inicio de una nueva
etapa para mí
debo de admitir lo que siempre me ha
gustado aprender gracias a mis padres
estuve en escuelas que me ayudaron a no
solamente desarrollar mi mente pero
también mi creatividad mis habilidades
de trabajo en equipo entre otras cosas y
gracias a mis maestros que se dedicaron
tanto tiempo en preparar lecciones que
realmente nutrieran mi conocimiento
estoy aquí
y creo que el esfuerzo combinado de
ellos y esas ganas imparables de
aprender se consolidaron cuando
terminando la prepa lo cual no fue hace
mucho tiempo se me otorgó una beca para
poder estudiar el extranjero por cuatro
años y estudiar ciencias políticas de
mercadotecnia e historia no mentía
cuando les dije que me gustaba estudiar
el compromiso de esta beca era utilizar
todo este conocimiento y traerlo de
regreso a mexico durante mi estancia
hice grandes amistades amistades que me
ayudaron no solamente a abrir mi mente
pero también mi corazón y estaba
convencida que la razón por la que había
estudiado todas esas y todas esas
carreras era que quería cambiar la
realidad de mi comunidad y más allá
cambiar el mundo
regresé a mexico
y empecé a hacer este compromiso empecé
a trabajar en algo de mi área trabajé en
la industria aseguradora en la industria
minera en la industria del mueble era
buena en mi trabajo y también pasaba
tiempo haciendo actividades de labor
social o de ayuda comunitaria en
diferentes organizaciones pero debo
admitir les que algo faltaba no sentía
esa pasión no me apasionaba realmente lo
que hacía sentía que había algo que
podía ser diferente y es por eso que en
agosto del 2014 decidió convertirse en
maestra me llega la invitación a empezar
en nuestra nueva era en esta nueva
industria de la educación y debo
decirles que en un inicio dije si esto
va a ser muy emocionante y nos vaya a
funcionar mucho hoy voy a poder
practicar las tantas cosas de mis
alumnos pero el día anterior
pensé creo que eso no lo debido derecho
esta no fue mi mejor idea porque empecé
a tener tantas dudas de cómo les voy a
compartir este conocimiento cómo voy a
asegurarme de que lo que les estoy
diciendo realmente les llegue y puedan
aplicarlo en sus vidas y también otra
cosa que muchas veces como maestros
ignoramos es que ya no vamos a tratar
con adultos
hablamos con niños adolescentes jóvenes
adultos que tienen ya sus ideas su
propio mundo no es lo mismo hablar con
un adulto con un compañero de trabajo
que con un alumno
y así empezó mi trayectoria siendo
maestra de mercadotecnia
inglés
historia pero realmente la materia que
marcó todo y la gran diferencia con una
materia con el nombre del liderazgo y
creatividad esa materia si ustedes oyen
el nombre pues suena realmente
prometedora para lo que se debe de hacer
pero yo al principio no sabía
exactamente cómo podía plasmar en un
semestre el poder brindarles a los
alumnos esas habilidades así que tuve
que empezar a recurrir a diferentes
recuerdos memorias experiencias que yo
viví durante toda mi vida para saber
cómo iba a poder lograr que ellos
también lo aprendieran porque más allá
del contenido de esta materia es
realmente desarrollar en ellos lo que es
su diferente tipo de liderazgo y cómo
ser creativos el primer día de clases
ellos llegan y preguntan maestra maestra
pero el líder nace o se hace no se
preocupe vamos a descubrir durante el
semestre o en el caso de la creatividad
maestra pero es que quien no se dibuja y
esa era su mayor preocupación porque
pensaban que solamente las habilidades
artísticas de habilidad
en lo que era la creatividad para ello
yo les comentaba yo creo que ustedes son
más creativos y más líderes de lo que
creen a poco cuando se juntan con sus
amigos para comer o salir siempre están
de acuerdo no debe haber el momento en
el que alguien tome la batuta y los
ayude a organizarse eso se olvida o en
el caso no sé de la vida diaria que
quieren ir a una fiesta o salir con sus
amigos o llegar más tarde se las
ingenian de alguna manera para que los
padres los dejen salir o lo típico que
creo que todos los maestros nos ha
pasado que llega el alumno y de alguna
manera ingenia una historia en su mente
o perfectamente detallada para que la
aceptemos un trabajo de último minuto
todas esas son diferentes formas de
creatividad y los alumnos a veces tardan
en darse cuenta de ese tipo de cosas de
que realmente sus habilidades las
muestran todos los días durante toda su
vida
así que empecé a pensar en este baúl de
recuerdos que puedo hacer para realmente
desarrollar esa creatividad y querían
tangiblemente que pueden tener un
resultado así que se me ocurrió una idea
y recordé una actividad que yo viví
cuando estaba en preparatoria para eso
les pedí a los alumnos que trajeran un
huevo crudo tape y popotes con esto y
van a poder crear un protector de huevo
si así como lo oye un protector de huevo
que les ayudará a proteger a ese huevo
crudo a que no cayera y se destrozado y
vamos a empezar con una altura de un
metro cincuenta sin más o menos y
después a un primer piso segundo piso
tercer piso a saber cuántas aguantaba el
huevo
en un inicio había mucha duda mucho
miedo preocupación de cómo es posible
que vamos a poder salvar un huevo nada
más con o con popote es que voy a formar
que voy a hacer algunos de ellos
empezaban a querer enrollar el huevo con
el tape pero eso no se puede o trataban
de hacer alguna figura arquitectónica
con los potes que realmente se veía muy
bonito pero perdí el sentido de poder
proteger el huevo y el resultado
realmente fue fascinante en el caso de
algunos alumnos crearon todo un
paracaídas para el huevo lo protegieron
perimetralmente toda una pieza
arquitectónica para poder proteger el
huevo sumamente confiados de que iba a
poder soportar esta gran batalla lo tiré
de este altura y el huevo se rompió
en un principio los alumnos estaban en
shock decepcionados tristes pero de
pronto empezaron a sonreír y se dieron
cuenta que era más de lo que esperaban
se dieron cuenta de las fallas de su
diseño que tal vez enfocarse más en
crear el paracaídas no le dieron
prioridad a lo que había alrededor del
juego para que pudiera soportar el
impacto entonces más que una excepción
se volvió en un reto de buscar
constantemente esas áreas de oportunidad
que ellos tenían
ahora en el caso del liderazgo que
podemos hacer para que los alumnos
realmente vean esas habilidades que
tienen dentro de ellos y cómo pueden
manejarse con el resto de sus compañeros
es difícil cuando tienes un salón con
tantas diferentes personalidades métodos
de aprendizaje y carácter pero en este
caso es cuando es más valioso hacer
diferentes tipos de actividades que
ayudan a que los alumnos se puedan
comunicar y que puedan aprender de ese
tipo de liderazgo como podía yo
enseñarles a mis alumnos acerca de
figuras históricas y grandes líderes
como nelson mandela o adolf hitler o
incluso porfirio díaz quien no solamente
tenían que tener liderazgo para poder
manejar toda una nación sino también
inspirar a tantas generaciones entonces
nuevamente buscando en esa vuelta
recuerdos recordé que había una
actividad en la cual podía organizar les
un rally a los alumnos cuando les hacía
el rally no solamente creaba que
tuvieran confianza entre ellos porque
había todo tipo de actividades que
culminaban en una última que realmente
ponía a prueba no solamente sus
habilidades
liderazgo sino el trabajo en equipo en
un inicio tenían que crear una silla
humana en la cual todos deben de hacer
un círculo deben de poder sentarse
y avanzar hacia el lado derecho a su
lado izquierdo o incluso saltar todo eso
indica mucha coordinación más que nada
confianza el que sepan que sus
compañeros no van a tener que lastimar
los unos a los otros y que realmente van
a poder cumplir con el objetivo en este
rally
la actividad principal y la que
realmente marcaba la diferencia es una
actividad que se llama edificios
llamamos nuevamente en equipos se coloca
una soga en una distancia de un poste
hacia otro a una altura de un metro 40
aproximadamente no lo suficientemente
alta para que no la puedan saltar pero
tampoco mente tampoco lo suficientemente
baja para que no sea desafiante para
ellos el reto es que todos los alumnos
deben de poder cruzar por encima de la
soga sin tocarla para poder aumentar el
nivel de dificultad de esta actividad
también se les pide en algún momento que
no hablen y que solamente una persona
tiene la palabra
esto ayuda a que reflexionen y sepan
quiénes realmente tienen que hablar o
qué necesidad tienen las veces de decir
instrucciones sí ya es claro si está
claro el objetivo no hay por qué estarle
repitiendo o incluso aprovechaban esos
momentos en que podrían hablar para
brindarle apoyo a sus compañeros y el
resultado nuevamente era impresionante
ver como ellos podían organizarse podían
hacer todas estas actividades sin salir
lastimados aprendiendo y descubriendo
tanto acerca de ellos mismos
suena sencillo cuando tienes una materia
que se llama liderazgo y creatividad
básicamente es algo que tienes que hacer
por sentado tienes que enseñar esas
habilidades más allá del contenido pero
qué sucede con esas materias en las
cuales no tienes esa ese título en el
nombre de la materia qué pasa con las
materias de química con las materias de
matemáticas o en mi caso con las
materias de historia como podía hacer yo
que mis alumnos pudieran aprender tanto
de diferentes figuras históricas de cómo
vivía la gente en ese tiempo sin
recurriendo más allá del contenido de la
materia entonces nuevamente decidí
pensar y recordar en ese baúl de
recuerdos que era lo que había hecho
anteriormente para poder despertar esa
creatividad el bit
recuerden una actividad que hicimos en
preparatoria en la cual teníamos que
crear una vestimenta y decidir juntarlo
con el marco histórico en este caso los
alumnos iban a crear una vestimenta como
proyecto final al principio estaban muy
emocionados porque decían si no tenemos
examen por fin entonces el mensaje
esos exámenes son horribles y todos
reprobamos
pero realmente ellos sentían que el gran
reto era el examen cuando les dije que
era un proyecto ya estaban brincando y
estaban haciendo ojos con sus compañeros
para ver con quién se iban a juntar no
sabían que se trataba este reto pero ya
estaban buscando cómo lo iban a resolver
hasta que les dije van a crear una
vestimenta de un periodo en particular
de cierta civilización pero que creen no
pueden utilizar tela
empieza el pánico la duda el no saber
cómo le van a poder hacer para realmente
resolver esto y lo primero que piensan
es foamy
hay más material en el mundo que for me
y empiezan a buscar diferentes formas de
crear las vestimentas ya sea con
manteles de plástico con cartón con
envolturas de papitas etcétera entonces
estos alumnos cuando están guiados para
poder crear esta vestimenta realmente
logran cosas simplemente maravillosas
utilizando simplemente plástico con una
cortina de baño y papel logran crear una
vestimenta de la antigua china
utilizando cucharas crean un collar que
hace referencia a los antiguos egipcios
y de una manera más sencilla utilizando
simplemente cartón pero con sus
habilidades artísticas lo convierten en
una armadura de un caballero medieval
y cabe también destacar que pudieron
lograr un vestido del renacimiento
utilizando tela de gallinero y enredando
servilletas para poder crear el volumen
de una falda
y ellos tenían todo en su mente
simplemente era poder darles las guías
para que lo pudieran desarrollar
y al final ese reto de esa preocupación
se convierte en satisfacción
algo sumamente importante es que más
allá de los proyectos podemos utilizar
este tipo de situaciones desde el inicio
del semestre o incluso en cualquier
momento de nuestra de nuestro contenido
en las aulas por lo cual yo prefiero
utilizar memes para enseñarles cuál
sería las reglas del juego y cómo deben
de comportarse en clase o qué es lo que
espero o espero que no hagan en el salón
como es en el caso del famoso from
pickup de decir mi cara cuando tú estás
hablando
y yo estoy hablando y es tanto que tengo
práctica de esa cara
qué
mis alumnos la pueden identificar
fácilmente y utilizando el humor también
es una manera única en los que ellos
recuerdan los mensajes y hay tantas
maneras de poder hacer esto
como hay maestros que les encargan
libros y que después lo vuelvan un cómic
o maestros que les piden que hagan
mandalas utilizando figuras geométricas
hay tantas herramientas que podemos
utilizar en nuestros salones y de todo
tipo de materias que enriquece realmente
la calidad educativa que tenemos hoy en
día también contamos con diferentes
plataformas somos una comunidad de
maestros muy grande alrededor del mundo
en la que siempre podemos compartir
ideas retos y como poder resolver estas
situaciones existen plataformas
aplicaciones existe tanto allá afuera
que podemos utilizar para que nuestros
alumnos juegan en el aula para que
puedan repasar material en sus casas
para que puedan realmente envolverse de
lo que están aprendiendo en clase
porque realmente esto es lo que les
ayuda a nutrir y en convertirse en
mejores individuos
la realidad es que somos creadores de
momentos momentos que pueden ayudar a
inspirar sueños momentos que también
ayudan a formar el carácter en ellos
momentos que definen el tipo de
ciudadano que pueden llegar a ser
creemos esos momentos convirtámonos en
creadores de momentos momentos que les
ayuden a definir el tipo de persona que
puedan ser momentos que los retén a que
puedan ser mejores personas no solamente
en su vida diaria o profesional pero que
se conviertan en la mejor versión de
ellos porque al final del día yo no
podría estar más de acuerdo con las
inmortales palabras de susan de anthony
la vida no se mide por el número de
momentos por el número de veces que
respiramos sino por los momentos que nos
roban el aliento gracias
[Aplausos]